>> From the library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Sandra McIntyre: Good morning.
I'm pleased to welcome you
to our panel presentation
on "Wide Open Spaces: Bringing
the Rest of the West Into DPLA."
You're going to hear from three
of us today who've been working
with DPLA staff to build out the on
ramp to the National Digital Library
for Cultural Heritage
Institutions in the West.
We have, first, Adrian Turner here
in the front row are my compadres.
Adrian Turner supports the
operations of the Online Archive
of California, OAC, and
Calisphere websites maintained
by the California Digital Library.
These sites provide
broad public access
to cultural heritage collections
contributed by libraries, archives,
and museums throughout California.
Next to him is Jodi Allison Bunnell.
She's the content creation and
dissemination program manager
at Orbis Cascade Alliance.
Jodi's responsible for
working with partners on unique
and local content, digital
collections, Archives West,
and archival collection management.
She holds an MA in History and an
MLS from the University of Maryland
at College Park and a BA in English,
summa cum laude, from
Whitman College.
And I'm Sandra McIntyre.
I'm the director of the
Mountain West Digital Library,
a regional digital collaborative
of libraries, archives,
and museums in Utah, Nevada, Idaho,
Wyoming, Montana, and Oregon.
MWDL was one of the initial service
hubs in the DPLA, and we share just
over a million resources
for harvest.
I have a bachelor's degree
from Swarthmore College,
a Master's in Education
from Georgia State,
and am pursuing an MSLIS
from Drexel University.
And just a little personal note,
on May 2nd I will be starting a
new position with another DPLA hub,
the HathiTrust Digital
Library, as the director
of services and operations.
Adrian and Jodi and I are
on this panel together
because we collaborate a lot.
Sorry. I should have had this up.
We collaborate a lot.
Our work overlaps.
We've shared a lot of
work on some initiatives,
and we have similar interests
in building out the on ramp
for the DPLA in the region.
While our organizations
sometimes overlap in who we serve
and what we do, we support
each other's work strongly
and celebrate each
other's successes.
We especially want to welcome
those of you in the audience
from other DPLA service
hubs and hubs in formation,
and we hope that our
presentation about our challenges
and successes will spur
discussion at the end
of the session among the hubs.
The community of service
hubs is an important part
within the DPLA initiative.
Jodi, Adrian, and I look
forward to hearing your ideas
for bringing the rest
of the West and the rest
of the country into DPLA.
So I'm going to give
a quick background.
And this is going to
look a little bit
like Emily Gore's standard
presentation
about the DPLA hub's network,
building on ramps for the country.
We think it's a brilliant
plan DPLA's come up with,
a distributed network that
leverages the work that's been done
around the country by different
collaboratives, different consortia,
and different individual
institutions.
DPLA's well known diagram about
how its hub network works shows
that it has the yellow content
hubs coming directly into DPLA
and the orange service hubs.
And we're talking today about the
challenges of the service hubs,
those groups that serve other
cultural heritage institutions
in aggregating and bringing in
content so that we represent regions
or states around the country in
sharing our materials with the DPLA.
So it's a very strong network.
It's been able to be very
successful, and I think I'm behind
about five or six states
here, judging from the one,
the slide that Dan Cohen [assumed
spelling] showed this morning,
so I know we should be adding
Michigan and Illinois and Wisconsin
and Pennsylvania to this map.
So congratulations to all
of you who've been
working on different hubs.
And congratulations
especially to Emily Gore
as this map gets filled out.
And we're looking forward
to it being completed
all around the country.
Thanks so much.
Yeah. So we've seen the success
of many different organizations
around the country.
You'll recognize many of your
friends and colleagues here
in the room and throughout DPLA Fest
from these different organizations.
I've been very pleased to work as
part of the initial set with folks
from Minnesota and South
Carolina and Georgia and Kentucky,
etc. And it's been delightful to
see new ones coming on board and get
to meet the New York folks in the
last couple of years, for example.
Some fantastic groups.
And these hubs share a
lot of common strengths.
And Emily's been very
wise to take advantage
of those common strengths
in contributing to DPLA.
Many of them are state based
collaboratives, state based funding,
and state based resources seem
natural to a lot of different groups
in reaching out to each
other to work together.
Some of them, many of them, are
centrally funded by some combination
of one or more of these, some LSTA
grants have helped some different
hubs to get going either
initially or an ongoing basis.
State legislative funds can
come into the picture for those
who are creative enough to
tap into that kind of support.
And then many major
universities play a chief role.
And from our perspective
in the West,
these are mostly relatively
resource rich states
that have been successful in coming
on board with larger populations
in the East, for example.
The opportunity to tap into at
least some wealthy cultural heritage
institutions and the ability to work
with historically quite rich
collaborations and consortia
who have built up over the years.
This is all contributing
to DPLA's great success,
a wonderful distributed network,
leveraging all the strengths
of our existing and new
collaborations around the country,
bringing in libraries, archives,
and museums from every
corner of the country.
Now Jodi is going to
talk to you a little bit
about the Western landscape and how
we're seeing some differences there.
Jodi?
>> Jodi Allison Bunnell:
Thanks, Sandra.
So I'll follow, as Sandra said,
her introduction to offer a summary
of the Western landscape
that, it's our intention
that contrasts a little bit
with what we've seen so far.
We see some strong differences in
geography, culture, and resources.
So geography.
We hear a lot about the
vast spaces of the West.
Even though I work in Oregon,
I am physically located
in Montana, so Big Sky, right?
But let's quantify exactly what
that means for each of our groups.
Here's the oops well, that is right.
Here's the geographic coverage
of the Orbis Cascade Alliance,
Washington, Oregon, and
a tiny bit of Idaho.
So if we drove from our southernmost
member, Oregon Institute
of Technology, to our
northernmost member,
Western Washington
University, that's 540 miles.
Add a trip to the east
to visit the University
of Idaho, and that's another 480.
Mountain West Digital Library,
including Utah and Nevada,
southern Idaho, a little
bit of Wyoming.
So if you start in Boise,
Idaho, and drive to Las Vegas,
Nevada, you've got 630 miles.
You visit the easternmost
partner in Cody, Wyoming,
that's another 400 miles.
And for California Digital Library,
I'm using a slightly different map.
This is the coverage map of the
online archive of California,
but it's a pretty good
map of the state
and the cultural heritage
institutions.
So I drive from Eureka to
San Diego is 765 miles.
Long distances, of course,
can be overcome by flying
if you have an airport nearby.
Depending on where you are
in California or Washington,
you're going to do all right.
There's actually a pretty
good number of major airports.
But Utah and Nevada have
four primary airports.
You're still going to drive.
Whether you're driving or flying,
we have a lot of mountains and,
therefore, mountain passes.
The difficulty of winter travel is
very much a factor if you're going
to go anywhere in the West.
If you're working with
small heritage organizations
that may have a number of
staff or volunteers over 50,
you'll quickly find that those
mountain passes are a huge barrier.
If you're going to have an
in person meeting or deliver
in person training, you have
six months a year to do it.
Second, culture.
So we've got a number of things
that we would argue are
special to the West.
And you can argue up against these
in the Q and A if you want to.
So we've got a big divide
between urban and rural areas.
And we know it has a potent
effect on western politics.
We see this in the composition of
our legislatures, for instance.
We have some really big differences
between the sectors of libraries,
archives, museums,
historical societies,
with their own distinct crowds
and professional meetings.
We have a lot of tribal
organizations,
a whole lot of tribal organizations,
with active cultural
heritage programs.
And there are some big
complications there
that are a presentation
in themselves.
Closely related, there are a number
of events in either the distance
or the recent past on which there
are really many perspectives
and a great sensitivity about how
those perspectives are handled.
And up last, the place of
religious organizations
in the history of the West.
One of my board members recently
commented in the northwest,
at least, we're practical utopians.
And, good heavens, what
am I doing with my slides?
Okay. Last, resources.
LSTA allocations, as we've heard,
have been a big source
of DPLA hub's funding.
LSTA is distributed
with a base amount
of $680,000 per state plus
an additional amount based
on population.
So that means that the less
populous Western states are
at a distinct disadvantage.
If we use the first letters of
states as a highly scientific way
of comparing across states, we
see big differences east to west.
Picture delivering services across
vast distances in Wyoming with less
than the funds allotted to tiny
West Virginia, for example.
This is real.
For a number of reasons, our LSTA
priorities at state libraries tend
to be really focused on very
basic public library needs
like internet access and
multilingual services or services
to populations that have
no library access at all.
Just as we are dealing with very
basic needs for library services,
we're dealing with very basic needs
for cultural heritage institutions.
There are places that
don't have a phone,
that close down their building
seasonally without a heat source.
It's hard to redirect such
small resources in the face
of these types of priorities.
Sorry. I keep going backwards.
Overall, higher education
support is lower
in many Western states
than it is in the East.
This graph of higher ed support per
capita by state shows that nicely.
Here are Oregon and Washington
in the lower quartile,
with Colorado second
from the bottom.
Utah, Idaho, and Arizona
are in the second tier.
We'll ignore Wyoming with its
highest per capita spending.
That's, of course, tied to the
state's vast coal and oil resources.
For other examples, the Oregon
University system is now independent
of state oversight, since it is
also independent of state funding.
And in early 2016 the University of
Montana announced, in my home town,
that it was laying off
205 FTE staff and faculty,
one fifth of its workforce.
In this environment you don't
see a state university stepping
up to take care of
everyone's digitization needs.
The resources to support the
public good are not there.
They're focused on direct
support for students and faculty.
What this adds up to is a great
need for cross state collaboration.
We don't have enough
population and resources
to support a merely a
state level collaboration.
We make a lot out of state
borders, but part of what we find
in cross state work is they're
really not that meaningful.
Cross state collaboration also
means a lot more complexity.
The great thing about this is
because, to varying extents,
our participating or member
institutions provide our funding,
and that means we don't
have the option
to make highly centralized
decisions or ones
that could be termed as by fiat.
We need to listen to our
members or partners very closely
because they are the ones
who provide the funding.
This is a situation
that demands strong
and consultative and
involved governance.
We can't get away with
anything else.
And this is just a summary of where
our three organizations are funded.
And as you see, there are
differences between us,
a range of member or contributed
funding versus central funding.
The Orbis Cascade Alliance,
my organization,
receives no central
funding whatsoever.
California Digital Library is a
different piece of the spectrum.
So that's the summary of
the Western landscape.
Vast spaces, topographic
variation, a diverse
and divided population,
and few resources.
All these things mean
that if we're going
to get anything interesting done,
we have to create more
complex organizations
that cross state borders, rely
on more complex funding models,
and that we have to have
really consultative governance
to be successful.
So I'll move from that.
I'll be the first of the three case
studies our three organizations.
So moving into a quick overview
of the Orbis Cascade Alliance.
Again, here's our geographic
coverage, Washington,
Oregon, and a tiny bit of Idaho.
We're composed of 39
academic libraries.
Here's the facades of 37 of the 39.
And our members represent
anything from the small two years
to the largest universities
in the region.
This graph represents the variation
in FTE across institutions.
We have a broad set of core services
that were built over
the last 21 years.
You see everything from our shared
ILS, physical delivery of things,
Archives West, one of the things
that I support, a vast student FTE,
the largest, I believe, hosted
aggregation of EAD finding aids
in the United States, and
a whole lot of databases.
We're headquartered
in Eugene, Oregon.
Our executive director, John
Helmer, likes to use this
as the picture of the staff.
This is the real picture
of the staff.
There are ten of us.
Now, how do we do all
this work with ten people?
I mentioned earlier a
$16.8 million budget.
The thing to understand is
that 11 point, excuse me,
I can't see my notes, $11.8 million
of that is electronic resources,
purchases, and that really all
but a million is passed
through to vendors.
So this is really how
we get things done.
This is our collaborative
workforce model.
It's composed of the
work that everyone does,
that a few do for all, known as W2,
and then this little teeny slice,
see this little teeny slice at
the top of the wedding cake?
That's the ten of us.
That's what is, what few do for all.
Some things about how we track that.
So we pay that top little teeny
slice through the consortium.
Oops. So, so like a good old
coop, we expect our members
to contribute not only money but
a considerable amount of time.
So that happens, again,
in our W2 space.
Now we've always done it this way,
but we have a new level of formality
about this under our
new strategic agenda.
Another part of this work inherent
in this model is a great
deal of trust in one another.
We have all of the policies and
frameworks that we need to have
in place, but we also have strong
relationships with one another.
We know one another, and we have to
in order to make this all happen.
Digital content aggregation was
just approved a month ago by council
as a new offering of our content
creation and dissemination program,
which, again, is our
unique materials program.
It will be supported by all
members, and we'll move forward
with aggregation using our brand
new Dublin Core metadata standards
next year.
Getting to yes on this
was a big deal.
Depending on how you look at it,
it was either a two year
or a nine year process.
I've been there for
the whole nine years.
There are a lot of factors that go
into that, but one of these speaks
to the fundamental
character of the alliance.
We decide to do new
things selectively,
really only when we can be
sure that everyone is committed
and confident in the initiative.
That means a process to bring
a diverse set of institutions
to a shared understanding,
which takes some time.
We never worked together
in this arena before.
In the late 1990s and 2000s
when many consortia dove
into centralized digital
asset management systems,
the alliance didn't.
So while we have a strong
and growing tradition
of working together
on many other things
around our purchase content,
this area is really new.
Here's a schematic of how
our aggregation will work.
We use an existing harvester
that feeds into our EAD database.
It, that will collect OAI sets.
We'll be extending it so
that it becomes multipurpose.
We'll feed into three
presentation spaces, Archives West,
as it's relevant, our
Primo Presentation
on our shared ILS, and DPLA.
As part of our approved digital
content aggregation for next year,
we'll apply to become a DPLA hub.
After some dialogue with the
DPLA staff, we're proceeding
with the understanding that
we'll initially be a hub just
for alliance members and commit
to a specific point not too far
in the future when we'll consider
service to non alliance members.
We're well prepared to do
that with no central funding
and other programs,
including our EAD program,
that serve non alliance members,
we've been making reasonable budgets
and transparent cost distribution
schemes for many years.
We have a clear model for
how we handle governance.
And so how we do this
isn't a problem.
So why can't we do this now?
Because our foray into
digital content aggregation
and moving toward hub
status is as much
as the organization
can consider right now.
With a clear and consultative
governance model that involves all
of our members, this work takes
time, and it's time well invested.
Here are just a few examples
of who we may be able to add
as participants in the future.
Not an enormous number of
institutions but enough
to make the effort worthwhile.
One of these, however,
and which you see
in the lower right hand
corner, is a catch all.
One of our most exciting
potential partners
with whom we're already coordinating
metadata cleanup this year is
Washington Rural Heritage, a program
of the Washington State Library
that provides digitization
and hosting
for many small institutions
without Washington.
So if I expanded the
map I already did.
See, you see many other
institutions.
So the building blocks are there
for a comprehensive
region wide service hub.
Last, we have some
challenges ahead of us.
With no previous tradition
of working together,
we know we'll be challenged
to begin the work
on metadata cleanup and aggregation.
As the New York folks talked about,
original formats, I
thought, ah, yes.
Original formats.
That will be fun.
Because of the way we've set
up Primo in our shared ILS,
the presentation of digital
objects in Primo will take some work
on our part and on Ex Libris's part.
Of course, taking the next
steps on the service hub,
participating in a national
conversation on the future of DPLA
and how it supports
teaching and research,
will be challenges
that we all share.
We're looking forward to
continuing to being part of that.
And now I'll hand off to Adrian.
>> Adrian Turner: All right.
So I'm going to talk about some
planning work that's actively
underway within California to
basically define a vision for
and develop a blueprint for
a service hub for the state,
basically a collaborative
service hub.
And the working title for
this thing a called CalDiSH,
California DPLA service hub.
So there's a lot of food
photos and stuff in here.
Either it will make you hungry for
lunch or it'll turn your stomach.
So in this map, I think,
is also out of date here,
but before I get going, you
know, I want to first kind
of paint a picture of, like,
a mile high view of kind
of what's happening in
California right now.
So within the California state we
basically have a number of services,
or, sorry, content hubs that
were established early on
or have recently come on board.
So we've got a lot of
content hub representation.
USC, University of Southern
California was, I think,
one of the first contributing
its own collections.
It's also taking partner collections
and then passing that on to DPLA.
The Getty Research Institute
is another content hub.
I think it's primarily
just Getty stuff.
The California Digital Library,
we came on board as a content hub,
what, a year and a
half ago or something.
We're passing on about, I
don't know, 400,000 objects
up to 480,000 objects now from
about 160 libraries, archives,
and museums in California,
passing that on to DPLA.
So we're kind of a weird content hub
in that we're aggregating
stuff and passing it forward.
And we also have a couple of other
content hubs that are kind of,
well, one is internet archive.
Kind of a macro hub.
So, as you know, they're
pulling in stuff from, you know,
throughout the states and passing
it on to DPLA, and then, of course,
David Rumsey map collection
based in San Francisco.
So we have a number of content hubs,
but we don't really have any
service hub in the states.
So, of course, that's
what we're planning for.
We do, though, have a number of,
and historically we've had a number
of organizations in the state
that provide some services,
some degree of services
for libraries, archives,
and museums in California.
But the coverage isn't really
comprehensive, and it's kind of,
you know, they have different
audiences and different kind
of memberships that they serve.
And they also have different
kind of service emphases.
So I won't go into detail into
all of them, but, you know,
some are membership
organizations like Califa
or the Statewide California
Electronic Library Consortium.
And they're doing things like
brokering licenses for, like,
ebooks and journals for, you
know, for public libraries.
In the case of SCELC it's
primarily academic libraries.
They're doing things
like hosting CONTENTdm.
We have other organizations like
Infopeople that provide training.
It's kind of like Amigos
maybe, you know,
outside of the California region.
We have, you know, a number of
cooperative library systems.
Then we have organizations like the
California Preservation Program,
which gets LSTA funding to provide
basically preservation training.
They're also doing a lot
of digitization support
for audio visual collections
right now
for organizations throughout
the state.
And then we have some
larger public libraries
like San Francisco Public Library
and Los Angeles Public Library that,
you know, could be really well
positioned to be able, maybe,
to provide things like digitization
services within their local area.
But right now, you know,
none of this stuff,
these activities are really
coordinated in any way.
So, I mean, I think the good news
is it's clear we have a pretty large
cast of characters
that could, you know,
maybe stitch together services
to, you know, form a service hub.
But there's not really one single
entity out here that, you know,
could do the whole, you
know, the whole thing.
So, and I think that situation might
be pretty close to other states.
You know, there's challenges
that we've had.
We don't really, again,
we don't really have a
statewide infrastructure.
I think the New York model we heard
earlier this morning hopefully many
of you were there.
I mean, that's kind of a nice
model in that there's this kind of,
you know, regional kind of
mini hubs within the state.
And we don't really
have that in California.
So we have a lot of organizations
that have done a lot
of digitization.
There's places like Los
Angeles County Public Library,
for example, massive collections.
The Huntington Library, for
example, a research library
with massive collections.
So, you know, these collections
are available to upload online,
but they're not really
available at the network level.
So, you know, there's
challenges there.
I think the opportunities
are really, again,
that we have multiple organizations
that, what we're really trying
to do is kind of form a
collaboration, you know,
a cooperative of the
willing to try to, you know,
basically stitch our
services together
and basically provide a
comprehensive set of services
for libraries, archives,
and museums in the state.
I think we've also really
benefited from the Library Services
and Technology Act
funding that's administered
through the California
State Library,
which has been really supportive
of digitization efforts
throughout the state.
So they've supported us,
they've supported, you know,
a lot of the organizations
that have, you know,
that I've mentioned earlier.
So, and I think the other
opportunity here, as I mentioned,
I mean, we do have a large
number of digital collections
that are available, you
know, through local sites,
local CONTENTdm instances,
past perfect instances.
I mean, these systems run the gamut.
They're just not aggregated or
available through DPLA right now,
but, I mean, I think we see this
stuff is, like, low hanging fruit.
If we could, you know, just harvest
this stuff, bring it together,
you know, we could
really make some inroads
into bringing these
California collections together
and making them available
at both the statewide
as well the national level.
So over the past year we've,
maybe past couple of years,
we've had some informal and maybe
more formal planning discussions
with a number of the
stakeholders that I've mentioned.
It's not just CDL.
It's all the organizations that I
was referencing earlier and more.
We've had some planning discussions,
and we've had more
planning discussions.
And I think it was last year,
last summer, we convened a meeting
at the San Francisco
Public Library hosted it,
and we basically articulated
kind of a collective vision
for this collaborative service hub.
Basically, what happened
at that point,
is an organization Califa
I mentioned earlier,
spearheaded an LSTA grant proposal,
put it into LSTA, and, boom,
we got some funding to really,
like, move this thing forward.
So, again, here's LSTA
really helping out.
So there's a steering
committee that's been formed.
And, in fact, some of our steering
committee members are here.
So Luis Herrera at the San
Francisco Public Library back here.
Do we have Matt Gainer?
Matt's not here.
Okay.
>> His boss is here.
>> Adrian Turner: Matt's boss
is here, so you can feel free
to contact us or talk to us,
you know, during the break
or after about, kind
of, what's going on.
But I just wanted to point out
there's a number of folks here.
We have Robin Chandler back
in the, on the couch there.
That's also helping out in
terms of this CalDiSH planning.
But basically I just wanted to
kind of get our vision up here.
I mean, this is kind
of the initial vision.
You know, get stuff up online.
You know, make California
Collections as widely discoverable
as possible through statewide
networks like something
like Calisphere as well
as, you know, maybe other,
other regional sites
that are maintained,
and then also through DPLA.
We want to do this together.
We want to do it in
a sustainable way.
So what we're envisioning is that
there's basically a whole kind
of suite of ingredients that we'd
provide as far as the services.
Okay. So kind of see them here,
but basically soup to nuts.
So consultation, training, you
know, providing DAMS hosting,
metadata services,
that's the vision.
We're anticipating that
there's going to be some stuff
that would happen maybe regionally
like onsite digitization support,
this whole "scanebago" [phonetic]
idea we're kicking around.
And then there might be
centralized services.
So like a preservation service.
Maybe an organization like USC
would be really well situated
to provide that.
And we're also seeing
basically a couple of ways
that these services
might be bundled.
So we're imagining kind
of an a la carte approach.
So there's organizations
like the Huntington
that have a pretty good program,
you know, and they, they,
they're building digital
collections.
So, you know, what they might want
is basically, like, preservation
or just the on ramp to DPLA.
So they might pick and choose.
And then we'll have kind of a
prefix kind of option for, you know,
organizations that don't
have a lot of capacity,
don't really have staffing to
get, you know, digitization done.
We want to design some services to
really, you know, give them kind
of a soup to nuts solution.
So we've had a lot of
stakeholder meetings.
I think probably dropping
the numbers here,
but all of these organizations
probably represent
over 900 libraries, archives, and
museums because they're, in turn,
working with different
organizations.
So we've really done a lot of
kind of information gathering
to basically validate this
vision and this approach.
Where we're at right now is we're
working on a strawman proposal.
The idea is to get that into
more of like a blueprint
for actually how this
thing will work.
We're starting to do
some business modelling.
So I think we've been reaching out
to some of the hubs in formation
to find out what kind of business
models that you've been developing
as well as existing hubs.
We need to define an organizational
home for this thing to get it up
and going as soon as we have this
kind of business model together.
And I think our next step is really
to get some pilot initiatives going
so we can actually, you know,
get some action and move forward.
So I think that's it.
>> Sandra McIntyre: Okay.
So the Mountain West
Digital Library was one
of the first six service
hubs in the DPLA.
We're really proud of the work that
we've done together and pleased
to be able to continue
to offer resources.
We've, we ourselves are
a distributed network,
as many other hubs are.
So we work with 19 different
repositories around the region,
each of whom or many of
whom host collections
from other collections
partners, and then we aggregate
into an Ex Libris server
and serve that to DPLA.
You've seen this map earlier.
Remember, repositories are
scattered around the West.
We anticipate, by the way, that
some of these states will spin off
at some point and become their own
service hub independently of us.
But we've been eager to help
out Emily as she's building
out the network in the West by
providing repositories who are ready
to go with an access to
the on ramp to the DPLA.
Our core strengths in Utah
and Nevada and some of Idaho.
We have a wonderful
new partner in Wyoming.
But I suspect some of the
Colorado folks will work eventually
with the Wyoming people,
etc. We have collection
partners in six states currently.
This isn't quite updated,
but we have over 190
different partners currently.
We have a portal, so we do try to
serve up a region portal for access,
and it's very popular with
many of our users, historians,
and genealogists among them.
And maintaining this in Ex Libris
Primo also takes some effort
from our staff.
We have over a million items
in 825 different collections,
a wide variety of resources, and
we really enjoy coming together
and bridging that gap as was
done here over 150 years ago.
And we knit it all together through
our interoperability standards.
We love sharing those with
other people, if you're looking
to get going on some
metadata standards
for your hub, your
hub and formation.
Let us know.
We can give you some advice
about what worked for us.
We have a combination of
metadata kinds of standards,
and our recent best practices
for geospatial metadata creation,
which we're really proud of.
We worked closely with Gretchen
Gueguen at DPLA to make sure
that those would be in line
with DPLA's harvest mechanism.
Our task forces are a big part of
how we operate around the region,
knitting people together
through virtual meetings,
task forces year round,
and that helps us
to keep this strong standards based
way of working together going.
We've also worked on standard
pricing, and I'll be talking
about this in another
presentation here at the fest.
Our funding began with a combination
of Utah Academic Library Consortium
funding in Utah, and then we were,
have also been assisted
by the University
of Utah's Marriott Library,
which has given us a
lot of in kind services.
And, of course, the wonderful
generosity of the DPLA
in including us in some of those
early digital hubs pilot project
grants made a big difference to
us in our growth and being able
to reach out to others
around the region.
Our exciting news is about our
long term sustainability program.
I'm very pleased that as part
of the DPLA funding we were able
to convene an MWDL advisory
committee for six months.
We had digital leaders, 19 digital
leaders from six states to come
up with the recommendations
report after staring really hard
across the table at each
other about how we were going
to sustain these functions,
these features, through the MWDL.
And as a result of that, we put into
place, and it's been very successful
so far, our first membership
program starting this fiscal year.
It's just asking for dues from
the harvested repositories,
those 19 larger institutions that
can afford to maintain a CONTENTdm,
a DSpace, an ArchivalWare, bepress,
etc. We don't charge directly
to the smaller collections partners
that are supported; however,
those groups do pay through
their digitization fees,
they pay to those different
repositories.
We've had good success so far.
We continue to pan for more gold.
As a part of that, is we included
more people in our funding mix.
We have also turned around and
said we want you more involved
in governance, and many of
them have really wanted that.
So we're now setting up
our first governing board
with this distribution of different
groups represented on the board.
We also have a very active
digitization committee
which meets as a whole twice a year.
And then the small working
groups, the task forces
and interest groups work year
round virtually and report
at those digitization
committee meetings.
And then we're pleased to
receive faculty support
at the University of Utah.
Some of the member questions
that we have are how to rightsize
that ungainly kind of lopsided
amoeba looking geographical region
that we serve.
And as new service hubs
emerge around the region,
we certainly expect that
that mix will change.
We want to continue to be responsive
to what DPLA needs in terms
of bringing new groups
in the West into DPLA.
But we also want to encourage state
based and other based collaboratives
that are forming to do their
thing and to serve their states
and regions really effectively.
We have some questions about how
to maintain direct services
in our new funding mix.
For new collection partners we used
to fund some centralized training.
We current have no funding for that.
So how are we going to manage that?
And then how are we going
to manage additional funding
for other efforts in the future?
So wrapping us up will be Adrian
talking about a couple of questions
about bringing the
West to the region.
And with our remaining few
minutes we want to open
up the floor for discussion.
>> Adrian Turner: So,
again, out of date map here,
but we tried to do some
shading in to show, you know,
the activity that we talked
about on the West Coast here.
And just to, you know,
basically put this forward.
Maybe those question marks
aren't lining up, but, you know,
what's going on in
the rest of the West.
And I think there may be
some of you in the room
who can help us answer
this question.
I wanted to point out that Texas,
Texas Portal History is a standing
DPLA service hub, so, you know,
this border may be, geography may
be a little bit arbitrary in terms
of what we're defining as
the West, but, you know,
what's going on in Colorado,
Wyoming, New Mexico, the Dakotas,
Nebraska, Kansas, how can we
get service hubs or, you know,
that activity off the ground there.
So we just wanted to
conclude with a few questions.
And, you know, basically if you
represent a DPLA service hub,
do you have any advice for us as far
as overcoming some of the challenges
that Jodi articulated at
the beginning of the talk?
And one thing I think we're all kind
of wondering about is, you know,
what steps have you taken
to implement a sustainable
service model for your hub.
And if you're at a library or
archive or museum and you're looking
for an on ramp to DPLA,
so you're in a state
that doesn't really have a hub, it'd
be great to hear from you, you know,
what do you perceive as some of
the biggest barriers to be able
to get your stuff to DPLA and
what do you think, you know,
what could we be, how
could it be overcome?
And if you could let us know if
there's hub ish [phonetic] things
that are happening in your state.
So, yeah. And if you
have any questions,
feel free to ask them as well, so.
>> Sandra McIntyre: So we're
throwing it open for questions now
or answers to some of these
questions, if you have some.
Yeah?
>> So I'm Mark [inaudible] the
libraries of the University
of North Texas, that's
the center of Texas hub.
>> Sandra McIntyre: Oh, great, Mark.
>> [Inaudible] we work
really hard in Texas to,
you know, do this kind of thing.
And we're trying to broaden it out
to other parts of Texas that are not
on the portal, other institution
with the [inaudible]
planning meeting.
We just had a meeting in Austin
of the Texas Visual Library.
Our directors are on it
and [inaudible] in Texas.
And I guess I don't have any great,
you know, insights beyond the things
that you've already said other
than, you know, it takes a lot
of hard work and conversation
[inaudible] and, you know,
due diligence kind of stuff
to arrange all those things.
And also I applaud
your efforts to think
through the sustainability
in advance.
>> Sandra McIntyre: Thank you, Mark.
I appreciate that.
I appreciate everything
you folks are doing.
Texas has got big size
problems, too,
but you guys are doing a great job.
And I'm glad to hear your update
on how things are coming
together there.
That's great.
Emily?
>> So I was going to, hub ish
activities happening in the West.
>> Sandra McIntyre: Yay.
>> So Oklahoma, I don't know if
anybody is here from Oklahoma.
If you are, awesome.
If not, [inaudible].
Oklahoma is very close to
submitting an application.
We've been working for them for
over a year in conversation.
And the Dakotas have
been talking very closely
with the Minnesota folks.
>> Sandra McIntyre: Excellent.
>> So I think that hopefully there
will be some activity there soon.
So, and I think there's
some conversations on this,
some folks are here from Colorado.
There's been some conversation
going on at the statewide rate
and other places about Colorado.
So I think there are some little
activities happening here and there.
But Oklahoma, I know, is actually
about to submit an application
to be, to have [inaudible].
>> Sandra McIntyre:
That's fantastic.
Would the person from
Colorado right, oh, good.
Lee, is that right?
Okay. Great.
Oh, good. Go ahead.
>> We are just in our initial
sort of planning [inaudible]
of a Colorado, possibly Wyoming, hub
coming together from different parts
of the Colorado state and Wyoming.
We started talking
about it [inaudible].
>> Sandra McIntyre:
That's wonderful.
Fantastic.
Best of luck to you on that.
Good. Other comments?
Yeah.
>> So the sustainability plan.
What is that going to fund?
>> Sandra McIntyre: So our
central staff you're talking
about for the Mountain
West Digital Library?
It will help fund our
core staff of 2.75 FTE,
our share of the aggregator annual
fee, which comes to about $15,000,
and then just minor things
like some contribution to some
of our really distant partners to
offset their travel to our meetings,
our own professional development
travel, things like that.
Yeah, the bulk of our
budget is in staffing costs
and then some technology costs.
And then we're also
obligated to start working
to reimburse our host
institution, the University
of Utah Marriott Library, for
many of the in kind services
that are provided for
technology, financial management,
human resources, etc. So we're going
to be creating a cost center
starting in the next fiscal year
to phase in reimbursement
for that support.
>> Could you share the
membership fees right now?
>> Sandy McIntyre: Sure.
Sure. No. That's fine.
I'm happy to say right now.
We started out with a discount.
Join now before it's
too late and it goes up.
So we started out with
yeah so we started
out with $5,000 per repository.
And we decided to do
it as a flat rate.
So it doesn't matter
what size repository
or how many collection partners
are supported on that repository.
It's a flat $5,000
for the first year,
and then it goes up $7,500 a year.
So we're about to send out
our second round of invoices,
and we'll see how many people renew.
We have pretty good support, though.
We did have a large
majority, a supermajority
of people to come on board.
We did lose a few repositories
either because they couldn't,
in the short term, request
the funding quickly enough.
We gave them about, only about six
months, and some organizations,
state based organizations
particularly need a lot longer
on their budget cycle.
Or because they are, as
Jodi was pointing out,
not resource rich enough
to be able to sustain it.
So we hope to get to the point where
we could offer sort of a scholarship
or an offset to some smaller
organizations, but I don't know
that we will be able to do
that because we're pretty
cut to the bone as it is.
Yeah.
>> Do you guys also
charge setup fees?
>> Sandra McIntyre: We do.
We have a one time setup fee,
acknowledging that much of the work
from our staff is involved in
setting up that aggregation
in the first place,
making the mapping work,
checking the metadata really
thoroughly, going back
and forth multiple times
typically over a couple
of months, to get that going.
Yeah.
>> Jodi Allison Bunnell:
She had a question.
>> Sandra McIntyre: Oh, there.
Thanks.
>> Like, so you're only, so it's
only 19 institutions right now
that are paying your fee?
>> Sandra McIntyre: That's correct.
The smaller institutions
that are supported
on those repositories don't pay
Mountain West Digital Library a fee;
however, on a project by
project digitization basis,
they have to pay the
digitization center
for the digitization processing.
Yeah. Which typically they get from
>> If an individual
institution is hosting now,
they pay the same $5,000?
>> Sandra McIntyre: Right.
And I think what we came down to
around that difficult
discussion table
when our different partners were
saying how are we going to do this
and everybody was pointing to
somebody else and saying, well,
your rich university can do it, or
your state agency ought to do it,
or, well, why has nobody got
the legislature in hand yet.
You know, that kind of discussion.
What we came down to was that if
the organization's large enough
to support, financially sound
enough to support a repository,
they're probably going to be one of
the more sound institutions fiscally
to be able to help
support this effort.
Yeah.
>> One more question.
>> Sandra McIntyre: Sure.
>> So what you said, what you also
said was, some of you recognize
that some of your states may go
out and set up their own hubs.
How many states are you
supporting right now?
Arizona, Montana?
>> Sandra McIntyre: So we
currently have records from Arizona,
but no one in Arizona has joined us.
So I think they'll
probably do their own thing.
But I anticipate we'll be retaining
the 19 in Utah, Nevada, Idaho,
Montana, one in Wyoming, and one in,
two, I guess, actually, in Oregon.
But I think there are obvious
places for different groups
to have their loyalties
and alliances over time
to build with other groups.
Yeah. Yes.
>> As a service hub, what
are your obligations to DPLA?
>> Sandra McIntyre: Do one of
you guys want to take that?
>> Adrian Turner: Maybe Emily
can lay down the law here.
>> Jodi Allison Bunnell:
Let somebody who signed
the agreement answer that.
>> Adrian Turner: Do
you want to go ahead?
>> Sandra McIntyre:
I can take a stab.
Yeah. Do you want to?
Okay. Well, I mean, I'll start
and you can than correct me.
To talk to our hubs about data
use and how to share metadata
with the DPLA, that
metadata we don't consider
to have copyright status, but to
the extent that anyone is mistaken
about that and thinks that
it does, they're agreeing
to assign a creative commons
zero license to the metadata.
And then to work hard to assign
all of the required fields
that DPLA has, which actually
are very few that are required,
but there are many
that are recommended.
And for good discoverability,
we really encourage our partners
to fill that, that complete map out
and to assign good
rights statements.
And that's something that's
such an evolving area.
I know in Mountain West Digital
Library we have a huge variety
of junky rights statements and a
long way to go to correct them.
>> Adrian Turner: I mean,
there's also a formal agreement,
I think it's online, so you
can see kind of the content hub
or service hub, what your
obligations are to DPLA.
I mean, there's, you know, you
know, being able to, responsiveness
and timely manner, you know, if
there's, like, take down stuff
that we need to negotiate with DPLA.
I mean, there's a whole,
you know, agreement.
So, you know.
>> Sandra McIntyre: And then
to pass on what we've learned.
I mean, if you become
a hub of the DPLA,
you'll want to share the
good news with others
and help them to come on board, too.
Yes, Mark.
>> Just a thought.
Would it be useful to have a webinar
with prospective members on the list
and talk through some
of these things?
>> Adrian Turner: Yeah,
I was thinking that.
I mean, we have a, there's an all
hubs list for established hubs,
right, but I think that's kind
of like the nascent hubs form.
We kind of need something like that
because I think we're all maybe
doing kind of back and forth,
you know, contacting
different, what, you know,
we just finally reached out to the
Ohio folks that are doing stuff.
You know, and, so there's a lot
of activity that's happening.
We don't have to reinvent the wheel.
So, but, yeah, I agree.
If there's some webinar, you
know, that we can, you know,
informally try to host
something or, yeah, but, yeah.
I agree. It would be
nice to have a little.
>> Sandra McIntyre: Mark, do
you want to kick that idea
around a little bit
with some of this?
Okay. That would be great.
>> Emily would be the [inaudible].
>> Sounds good.
>> Sandra McIntyre:
That would be great.
Yeah.
>> I just wanted to ask about
what kind of opportunity you have
in these, talking with all of
these different partners to talk
about digitization priorities.
You know, how to make our
collections more diverse,
more culturally representative
in ways that they may not be
if we're just, you know,
digitizing here and there.
>> Sandra McIntyre: You
want to comment on that?
>> Adrian Turner: Well,
there's actually a complementary
project that's happening
where I think we're just trying
to even get a sense of kind
of the data points, what
collections are out there
that haven't been digitized.
That might then help LSTA start
to target particular funding for,
you know, scanning efforts.
And I think this could
start to really dovetail
with this CalDiSH initiative.
So, and Robin Chandler
over there is coordinating
that particular project.
It's what, "Finding
Your California?"
So, you know, I think it's kind of a
broad survey of what collections are
out there, and I think that's going
to be the starting
point then to identify.
It's almost like hidden collections.
>> Sandra McIntyre: And then
on a really general level,
maybe not digging into quite the
level that you were talking about,
but the wonderful curriculum
that a number of us collaborated
on to create an online curriculum
through the Public Library
Partnerships Project funding
that DPLA received from the Gates
Foundation has a content selection
module to it.
So, but that's, of course, a very
general introductory coverage.
By the way, that's a great
curriculum, and we'll be talking
about that also at the fest.
Look for that PLPP presentation.
>> Jodi Allison Bunnell:
And although it happens
on an institutional level within my
participating institutions who are
in Archives West, many of them use
the metrics that I send every month
on their usage of their
finding of retrievals in order
to drive their digitization
priorities.
>> Sandra McIntyre: I'm going
to take one more question.
Lisa [assumed spelling],
did you have your hand up?
>> I'm sorry [inaudible].
>> Sandra McIntyre: Okay.
>> I was just going to give you
my thoughts on the base barrier.
And I say this knowing full well
that you started off talking
about the travel, but I think
the things that we personally,
folks that have come
on board [inaudible]
yet would be greatly aided
by us being able to go
to their institutions and sit
down and look at their systems.
And also show them kind of
the step by step [inaudible].
I think that one on one would
probably be, if we were able to fund
that and get that done, it would
probably bring in those laggers
who are, like, on the edge.
>> Sandra McIntyre:
Thanks for that tip.
Thanks for that advice, and I know
Minnesota digital library has done
that sort of itinerant
outreach to great effect also.
And folks in Digital Commonwealth
in Massachusetts, so, yeah.
Oh, there.
You are the person.
All right.
Great. Well, thank you all
for your attention today.
It's been a pleasure to talk to you.
We'll hang out for a few
minutes afterwards for anyone
who has any other questions.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.